there is a breakdown a fundamental
breakdown right now that's happening in
society and some of that deals with the
way a lot of these women and some men
but a lot of these women that we see on
the panels talk about the fluidity of
their sex but but by the way on that I
mean I don't mean wow that could be
totally misinterpreted what I just said
oh what did I exactly mean double
entender what I mean is that the
fluidity with which they have sex with
everyone and everything that walks not
good
um you know this hyper promiscuity this
female promiscuity is empowerment this
you know sex in the city slash
kardashian-esque culture that we now
Embrace as as young people in society
that's all bad
that's all bad so that's leading people
down this dark hole of degeneracy